ce vendredi matin et saint quentinois se
sont réveillés les pieds dans la neige
un petit manteau blanc de quelques
centimètres qui ne devrait pas
d'ailleurs s'attarder pas vraiment une
surprise depuis jeudi après midi les
services de météo france avait lancé une
alerte orange pour le département des
yvelines
une alerte maintenue jusqu'à ce vendredi
en milieu d'après midi les services
techniques des mairies et les sociétés
concernées ont donc été mobilisés dès
jeudi soir
les saleuses ont fait leur apparition
pour un traitement préventif de la
chaussée comme ici aux alentours de 23
heures aux abords du quartier du mas
nerfs montigny le bretonneux
c'est dans cet entrepôt de trappes que
sont stockés les 1200 tonnes de sel qui
seront utiles pendant la période
d'activité du plan neige sur
l'agglomération soit jusqu'à la fin du
mois de mars les grands axes
prioritaires et les axes secondaires
sont déterminés selon une carte des
circuits de passage sont ainsi décidée
bien en amont on a dix 10 camions neufs
camion donc pour la casse qui est un
camion pour la ville de montier
partenaires dont dépend des communes les
communes s'ils ont besoin qu'on
intervienne autant de fois qu elle
il nous appelle et on sera sur le comedy
side c'est voilà sept jours sur sept 24
heures sur 24
au moindre petit signalons on à faire
bien